hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the 2020 Tata Steel
masters edition it's for me Annika Rana
who is leading tournament by a full
point lead against a young shoe stop
Duda with the black pieces now it's it's
really too complicated of a game even I
think it's been a while since we had a
game this complicated but that's what
happens when two two engines
preparations meet I guess and then well
a lot of things can go wrong so without
further ado let's check it out Fabi
would the white pieces opens with d4 we
had Knight to f6 c4 sorry about that
and the e6 we have g3 by Fabi
and now d5 we rush up the g2 so the the
Catalan is on the board we've got up to
e7 Knight to f3 and the castles we have
castles by Fabi and B captors and c4
that's all fairly standard stuff Queen a
for going after the pawn and now most
often here is a 6os the Queen captures
b5 and then you retreat with the Queen
to c2 but here do that goes for c6 it's
been played it's a bit of a different
approach but Fabi continues in in the
same fashion Queen captures and c4 b 5
and now not going to see two but Queen
back to b3 so what's what's the
difference Duda continues Bishop to b7
we have looked at e1 now you want the
rook to to a nice open semi open file
not open semi open but a semi open file
Knight B to d7 eyeing that nice c5
square if possible at some point you do
want to play c5 and here comes Knight to
e5 dinkler and had this position against
me tree under 18 and he played Bishop to
g5 in this position that game ended in a
draw but here we have Knight to e5
Knight captures on e5 pawn captures on
e5 and now tonight back to d7 you cannot
go here because efore just wins the
night you cannot move the knight so we
have Knight to d7 and now Bishop to f4
guarding the pond here developing Queen
to c7 unpinning from the rook and now
there is a one game that was played it's
a really notable game in the candidates
tournament
20 1811 Ariane vs Sergey Carrick in
Knights the d2 was played in that game
severe Kerrigan was able to win it but
here in night the sea 3 by Fabi and this
is now a new move so as of move 14 we
have a completely new game now that the
sea v square is available for do last
night
he of course occupies the knife to c5
Queen back to C tube and now B for
grabbing more space kicking the knight
further back nice the b1 and now rush up
to a 6 so do the grabbing a lot of space
pressuring the e2 pawn so Bishop to f3
now the point is nicely defended and
here rook a to c8 this pawn will be it
will be under fire so you want to move
the knight at some point and hopefully
start pushing the the C pawn so a3 Bobby
puts pressure and makes you do that
decide what he's gonna do here and here
Duda plays b3 is an option this is what
Bobby wants he wants the b3 he moves the
Queen and then he again gains the c3
square for his Knight but here do the
place rook to b8 and believe it or not
the when do the play the rook to b8
the engine is just screamed that this is
a mistake now it's hard to find why this
is a mistake but I will let you find why
this is a mistake so feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out this
this whole mess well while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
as its well I do believe that this is
not possible to find because well Fabi
didn't find it and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
actually a captures on b4 rook capture
some before and now brush up the d2 this
Bishop to b2 is a deadly move here
instead of Fabi play Bishop to e3 but at
explain why Fabi played Bishop to e3 we
first have to check bash up the D to
measure up to d2 seems a reasonable
because if you move the rook for example
rue goes back before just wins for white
you either lose the night or you move
the knight and lose the bishop so
obviously it's that simple
so instead after Bishop to b2 that the
engine doesn't move the rook the engine
just gives up the rope so here you can
just capture it and after
Dress your up material and you feel good
about yourself I mean you're out the
exchange black has no compensation here
okay he's somewhat the more developed
the but doesn't doesn't really explain
why this so when I saw this Bishop to b2
by the engine I thought to myself why
not rugby 3 and it's it's really well
yeah I I'm not saying it's a good
question but it's it's hard to say why
rook to be three isn't good for black
but this is the engine says this is also
winning for a while but I guess for for
immortal and I mean Fabi didn't go for
it too so it's hard to the hard to
decipher but the engine gives the bishop
the c3 this is a crazy stuff with the
idea that the bishop wants to go to d4
attacking the knight and then again put
pressure on the a6 pawn by attacking the
knight you not only put pressure on the
a6 bone but also on the rug because the
knight guards are both of those so here
queen c8 now taking some pressure all of
the night so the queen is now guarding
the bishop now Knight the d2 you attack
the rook route goes to b6 and now the
shop the d4 push up to d4 now with a
double attack so you have to defend it
let's say rugby 5 and the now comes a 3
so what do you play here whatever you
play it's hard to find the move for
black because there's so much pressure
for example Ruby d8 now b4 and now you
either capture and give give up a piece
here or you do something else it's hard
to hard to decide what would say 97 and
now you allow this capture of the pawn
Queen captures on c6 and this seems
seems to be winning for white now with
with so much pressure on unwise pieces
but yeah really really insane stuff but
that's just what happens after Bishop to
b2 it's impossible to calculate and well
it's obviously impossible even for
number 2 player in the world Fabiana
Caruana so he played the more human
approach of the ship the e3 instead I
just going after the defender of the
bishop on e6 but now Queen to b7
defending and also putting pressure on
the beat you
so here car wanna play tonight's 2d to
allowing Duda to capture the b2 pawn we
have rook captures unbe to in the now
Queen to c3 again putting pressure on a
lot of pieces if you capture this thing
you can capture this then you can
capture this if Queen recaptures a lot a
lot of tactics in the air so here look
back to b5 adding another defender to
the c5 pawn has now the c5 Knight as the
knight is attacked twice and now rook to
a3
now Fabi makes room for the other roof
to come to a-1 he wants to double up and
the will a wreak havoc along the a file
so Queen back to b8 now putting putting
pressure on the e5 pawn and also making
room for the bishop so the bishop can
retreat and here you have to decide what
to do for example if you try something
like Bishop characters on c5 and now you
get rookie actress on c5 and now it's
not a problem the Queen is under attack
so you don't have a chance to capture
the bishop on e6 however well okay you
go look to a-1 you you put pressure on
the bishop bishop moves and then you can
capture the a7 point so this is one way
to go about it the other way is the
capture and c6 this is a reasonable move
you eliminate the pawn attack the rook
once the rook moves you move the bishop
and again you can play rook rook detaii
one and put pressure on the a file Bobby
decides that okay this is a this is
always possible I'm just gonna double up
instantly
now again I'm threatening just to pick
up to pick up the night but also there's
just the rook captures on a6 this is
actually still not a threat because the
rook will attack the Queen but this is
so we have busted back the b7 and then
now rook captures an a7 by Fabi
Knight to d7 now on pinning and well you
no longer have threats along with the c
c5 square and you are preparing to push
c5 if you can play c5 then you your
position becomes much better because you
no longer have a target on c6 you open
up this diagonal so you can maybe trade
light square bishop and the lives it
just becomes easier so nice to see four
by fobbing eyeing that juicy d6 square
and now rook to d8
by Duda
Bishop to e4 now putting pressure well
on the entire board really and now
finally c5 opening up and an opportunity
to trade and here the situation on the
clock is 25 minutes fabi's six minutes
Duda so this is only move 27 and this is
how much time they burn both of them
calculating the dismantle so Queen to c2
by Fabi he keeps the tension now
threatens to capture on on age seven and
if you capture this doesn't really do
anything for you just allow the white
queen to become perfectly centralized
and just controls the entire board so
not really anything to be gained so h6
and here
Bishop to d2 by Fabi and just I believe
just Reema nuvaring the Bishop to ax to
a nicer square letting Duda burn more
time we have nice to f8 now opening up
the e-file for the rook and also the
knight will be very useful here guarding
the h7 square Bishop to d3 now and this
is even worse for Duda because now he
was constantly calculating the trade
here but now with I believe less than
three minutes on the clock he again has
to reassess the position and here Duda
played rook to d7 which makes sense if
you try something like Knight back to D
7 it's actually pretty bad because
Knight to d6 opens up a discovery to the
rope for example 96 you attack the rook
rook moves and now you have this very
very nasty Bishop h7 check so the night
on f8 was a really important guarding
that h7 Square so if you go here Knight
f7 is made that's that would be a
terrible way to go
so after Bishop d7 he would have to go
here but still Knight captures on f7
King captures and now you have to remove
one of the defenders of the e6 squared
which is the rook here
so root characters here rook captures
and now Queen to g6 with check King f8
and now Queen captures on e6 threatening
mate and the only way to avoid mate is
Knight to f6 so e captures and f6 would
have to be played Bishop captures and
now Bishop therefore wins for Fabi just
attacking the Queen if you move the
Queen Bishop to d6 is is nicely winning
so really really incredible stuff
and this is something dude ahead like a
few few minutes the calculate been
before he runs out of time so he decided
Luke the d7 required less calculation
and now tonight study six again by Fabi
opening up a double attack on the rook
here rook the b6 and now queen chapters
and c5 so to avoid calculating that mess
which could easily have gone wrong for
him he just gives up a pawn on c5 so
here Fabi wins a clean pawn bishop to d5
now opening up an opportunity to trade
once again so far because rook captures
we have Knight captures and then out
comes Queen to c8 check and Duda cannot
accept this trade because after captures
captures the bishop and the rook are
under attack you would have to play
Bishop c5 and give up the exchange
so after this check we have Knights the
f8 by Judah and then out comes Queen
captures on b8 by Fabi again I will
mention it because it's really too
complicated of a game the trip the e3
seems to be the way to go here because
again it's hard to decide what to do
there's the forcing line of Bishop
captures on d6 followed by Queen
captures rook captures and now II
characters on d6 and once you go after
the passed pawn now Luke a6 defends the
pawn and now the bishop pair will nicely
escort to that point you will first kick
away the Ruby then you're gonna bring
the bishop into the game and the two
squares the pawn needs the the cross are
nicely covered by the bishop pair
problem is after Bishop to e3 Duda has
ripped the b4 which is also an idea but
now again this engine move rook the c1
is just stupid again giving giving white
as as winning here because there's not
much to do really you we again said that
you should not trade Queens if you try
characters and captures doesn't really
do anything for you let's say Queen
captures on d6 you you run into Bishop
c5 just winning material so what you
could do after rook before
rook c1 the the this
casting engine move we discussed is
maybe waste a move with h5 but still if
you allow look to c7 which is the thread
behind the rook to c1 it's it's just
over so you don't have a good move here
to Queen captures rook captures and this
is now well - too difficult to hold for
black
it would seem but yeah those are those
are disgusting engine lines that lurk in
the position Fabi instead it went for an
ice queen capture so he traded Queens we
have route capture sin b8 and now comes
f4 here maybe Fabi was thinking about
going looked a 7 right away but it
doesn't work yes the bishop is under
attack if you move the bishop then the
f7 pawn Falls
however rook to e8 is possible for for
Duda here and now if you capture you're
getting made it Roque 1 the bishop
covers g2 you have to block give up some
material and it's made so after this
rook captures nb8 at the Queen trade
first f4 now making some breathing room
for the king but now Bishop d8 again
Duda finds a creative way of how to
prevent rook to e7 because the ship to
b6 check picks up the rook so again not
possible so far bee starts improving the
position of the King King f2 now Knight
to d7 do that starts to bring in the
night into the game Bishop e3 now okay
now maybe the rook can finally come to a
7 but now g5 by Duda and this is now
move 38 so they need to make two more
moves to reach time control Bishop to d4
by Fabi just improving the position of
the bishop the d5 pawn will also be
nicely guarded and now look the b4 by
Duda if you go for characters captures
and look the H for which seems awesome
King III and the King it will be very
very safe on e3 front from dudeism
bishop pair so instead look at the b4
was played attacking the bishop and here
Fabi just played King to e3 and here
Duda has 30 seconds to decide what move
he's going to play before reaching time
control and he decides for G captures on
f4
there's a there was a better move but
again in 30 seconds finding f6 is not
all that possible
it just keeps the tension and doesn't
give Fabi anything for example if Bishop
to c3
now you
she captures on f/4g captors and it has
a shop to be six check pushing the king
away from the defense of the f4 pawn and
now if after the King moves you can pick
up the f4 pawn so this this will be good
for black but with thirty seconds on the
clock the reach time control do the
plate G captures on a four-wheeled G
captures on f4 and now King to f8
wanting to improve the position of the
king but Bishop to b5 Fabi doesn't allow
it now if you do some Viking e7r okay
seven wins
there's no way to guard the night you're
gonna have to give up the exchange here
so after this Bishop to b5 Duda played
the incredible Knight to f6 it's just a
just a beautiful move and the Fabi took
a good thing here but you can also do a
good thing here feel free to pause the
video and try to find what do you play
here so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations if you found
Bishop the c5 that that's a disgusting
engine move so really congratulations
but if we just decided to capture the
night
that's what Fabi played and it's also
also sufficient so we're gonna discuss
because the point is after Knight
captures of course do the played rook
captures making it impossible for the
King to recapture because of Bishop
captures on f6 followed by Bishop
captures on a1 so that's why Bishop to
c5 of course comes to mind Bishop c5 and
now both the rook and the knight are
under attack but not not all as simple
as it seems
here Duda would have Knight to g4 check
you'd have to move king D to and then
now rook captures on f4 so you give up
this pawn and now
efore is the move you have to find if
you play that disgusting engine line but
now again the bishop doesn't move Bishop
to g5 threatening nasty discoveries for
example rook f1 I discovered to check
picks up again the rookin a1 you would
have to play King to c2 to get away from
there and now after Bishop to b7 rook to
e7 finally wins the bishop so really
just insane
so after Knight of 6 Fabi of course he
doesn't want to burn a lot of time here
he finds that this will be sufficient we
look after sandy for and now Fabi plays
rook
and now the point is there is no more
this trick of kinky actress rookie
actress and f6 picking up the rook now
Bobby's just threatening to go up the
board so Bishop captures on f6 this
defends the rook but now Bobby just
plays rook to c7 and here there are a
couple of moves that you might try and
play but there's nothing to do against
just losing a lot of material here so
for example you could open up an attack
towards the knight problem is rook
captures on f7 King g8 you're gonna
capture on f6 rook captures and e6 but
you also pick up the h6 pawn and it's
three points to one completely winning
for white so instead do the played
Bishop the 88 but now for the last time
in this video feel free to pause the
video and find the winning idea for Fabi
well the cleanest winning idea well I'll
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who found rook captures an
f7 that is of course winning but there
is a cleaner way rook the c8 check this
is what Fabi played and well now the
point is if King g7 and the bishop no
longer guards the rook so it's a free
rook
so of course do the play King the e7 but
now it's just rook captures a nitrate
now if you capture the knight again it's
a free rogue there's no more Bishop on
h8 guarding it so here look the b4 was
played saying okay I'm still threatening
this if you move it maybe I win my piece
back but Knight the c8 with check by
Fabi
King f6 and now Bishop to d3 and it was
in this position in unmoved 49 that
young crystal dude I resign the game and
this I mean this was it was the the most
difficult game to present to you guys
and the most difficult game to analyze
because well nothing it was normal here
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I will now mention
something about the standings so if you
don't want it spoiled you know maybe
maybe stop watching the video now but
for those of you who enjoy learning
about the results Fabi who actually wins
the Tata Steel masters edition with his
win here one whole round before the
tournament ends because Magnus drew his
game against Artemia and by winning
against Duda Fabi extended his lead to
one and a half points so even if he
loses in the final round and the Magnus
defeats Wesley so still will not be
enough Fabi still wins the tata still
masters edition 2020 and it's
interesting to see what this means for
the for the ratings for example these
are the libraries for from the website
2700
chest 2700 so here you can see Carlsen
lost eight points even though he's doing
extremely well across and it's currently
second in the standings but his rating
is is so huge that he took a nice blow
he lost eight 8.1 points he can still
make up for it if he wins against West
tomorrow but Fabi 115 points so far in
the tournament which means that he he
extended his lead from Dingley Rijn as
you can see being is 2805 Bobby is now
28 37 these are live ratings so they are
not official they will be official if
they remain the same until February
first but yeah I just want to share that
as well as Pham that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it we'll see what
happens in the other games and of course
we will continue our coverage in the
final round I would like to thank about
marine 54 Marion village dog McNab now
Victoria the rulli's and bus guarding
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos sure thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata Steel checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and of
course continuing the Paul Morphy saga
so thank you I will see you soon and
congratulations on staying all the way
to the end of this video I have an
excellent rest of your Saturday